THE SERIES OPENER.
LET'S GO DOWN TO REBECCA
HAARLOW.
>> Rebecca: DONOVAN, CONGRATS.
WHAT A BALL GAME.
I MEAN, THAT LAST POSSESSION,
THE CLIPPERS HAD A CHANCE TO TIE
THIS THING UP.
YOU GUYS DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE TO
COMMUNICATE DEFENSIVELY.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> Rebecca: WHAT DID YOU SEE ON
THAT POSSESSION?
>> WE SCRAMBLED ON THE FLY.
YOU KNOW, I THINK, THE BEST
THING -- WE JUST WERE
INSTINCTIVE.
RUDY MADE A HELL OF A PLAY.
THAT'S WHY HE IS DEFENSIVE PLAY
OF THE YEAR.
>> Rebecca: YOU ARE GETTING A
LOT OF MVP CHANTS RIGHT NOW
DONOVAN.
>> YEAH.
>> Rebecca: BUT THE TURNAROUND
IN THIS GAME STARTED IN THE
THIRD QUARTER.
THE FIRST TWO AND A HALF MINUTES
YOU SCORED TEN STRAIGHT POINTS.
WHAT WAS YOUR FOCUS AT THAT
POINT?
>> OH, MAN, I LET MY TEAM DOWN
THE FIRST HALF ON BOTH ENDS OF
THE FLOOR.
I LET REGGIE AND LUKE GET HOT.
I WENT INTO THE LOCKER ROOM AND
I WASN'T MAKING THE RIGHT READS
AND I SAID GUYS, IT'S ALL ME, I
HAVE TO SET THE TONE.
WE DID OUR THING.
>> Rebecca: WE SAW DWYANE WADE
OVER THERE.
YOU WERE CHATTING ALL NIGHT
LONG.
THIS WAS A WILD GAME.
DID HE HELP YOU WITH AED VICE.
>> YEAH, THINGS HE SAW.
IT IS SOMEONE THAT I CALL MY
BROTHER SITTING COURTSIDE BEING
PART OF THE ORGANIZATION TRYING
TO HELP ME OUT AND FINDING WAYS
TO IMPROVE, NOT JUST MYSELF, AND
FINDING WAYS FOR THE TEAM.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST THING.
I AM GRATEFUL HE'S ABLE TO DO
IT.
NOT A LOT OF GUYS CAN DO THAT.
ESPECIALLY LIVE ACTION IN A
PLAYOFF GAME.
IT WAS GREAT.
>> Rebecca: WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
FIRST HALF VERSUS THE SECOND
HALF WHAT'S THE TAKEAWAY?
>> YOU HAVE GOT TO PLAY HARD.
THEY ARE A TALENTED TEAM.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE DID
SOME THINGS WRONG, THEY DID SOME
THINGS WRONG.
WE HAVE TO ADJUST FOR IT.
WE HAVE TO COMPETE EVERY SINGLE
DAY, EVERY SINGLE SECOND.
CREDIT TO THEM.
THEY CAME OUT.
IT IS GOING TO BE A DOG FIGHT
FOR THEM, TOO.
WE HAVE GOT TO BE READY.
>> Rebecca: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> Ian: REBECCA THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
DONOVAN MITCHELL WITH A
TREMENDOUS PERFORMANCE.
A HOT TOPIC WILL BE THE FACT
THAT THE CLIPPERS HAD A TIME-OUT
REMAINING THEY ELECTED TO PLAY
IT OUT.
ENDED UP IN SCRAMBLE MOETDS.
>> Greg: I HAD NO PROBLEM WITH
IT FOR A COUPLE OF REASONS.
ONE, WHEN YOU HAVE THE VETERAN
EXPERIENCE AND TALENT THAT THEY
HAVE YOU DON'T WANT TO ALLOW A
GREAT DEFENSIVE TEAM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GO BREAK DOWN HOW
THEY WANT TO DEFEND IT.
YOU HAVE TO CREDIT UTAH FOR
BEING BETTER.
THEY WERE DISCIPLINED IN THAT
LAST POSSESSION AND DIDN'T ALLOW
FOR A GOOD LOOK.
THEY GAVE THEMSELVES A CHANCE
THE CLIPPERS DID, IN A GAME
WH